[Musique]
la
n
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
oh [
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
a [
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
J'ai
eu peur de  j'avais raté la chance de
la vie oh ma chérie et au fait, hé,
je suis tombé avec une fille romantique et je
ne
pleure pas mais maintenant
je cherche chaque
étoile, je continue à chercher de près et de
loin chaque porte jusqu'à ce que je trouve notre seul
Esprit  voler haut
en volant
haut ne jamais l'abandonner ne jamais l'
abandonner même quand cette vie est finie ne jamais l'
abandonner ne jamais l'
abandonner même lorsque cette vie est finie ne jamais l'
abandonner ne jamais l'abandonner
même lorsque cette vie  c'est
fini, je serai content dans le
temps [Applaudissements] [Musique] [Applaudissements] et donc
aujourd'hui je pense que je vais prendre une
chaise oh
chérie et au
fait je tombe en amour ma fille et ça ne me
dérange pas parce que maintenant
j'atteins  pour le
fils Angel disant que l'amour est juste une
supplication de se
tourner vers un seul Esprit qui vole
haut, qui vole
haut, n'abandonne jamais, abandonne
quand la vie est finie, n'abandonne jamais, ne l'
abandonne jamais, même quand cette vie
est finie, ne l'abandonne jamais.  je ne vais jamais
l'abandonner même quand cette vie est finie je me
contente
du temps je n'abandonne jamais je ne vais jamais l'
abandonner même quand la vie est finie je n'abandonne jamais je vais l'
abandonner quand la vie
est finie je n'abandonne jamais  y
renoncer même quand la vie est
telle que je suis content je vais être
[Musique]
content je n'abandonnerai jamais je vais y
renoncer même quand cette vie est finie
ne jamais l'abandonner ne jamais l'abandonner
Je suis
content et
TI n'abandonne jamais, je l'abandonnerai même
quand cette vie est finie, je ne serai jamais bon, je vais
abandonne-le même quand cette
vie est finie, je ne le donnerai jamais
quand c'est la vie finie, je serai dans le
temps maintenant je vais me donner un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du temps
J'adore
[Musique]
pour la
jolie pop CST  pop pop po
[Musique]
spee
pour
[Musique]
pour po
en pop po [
Musique]
po a [
forke [Musique
]
pour Sal [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la
tout
[Musique]
coeur le
héros Les anges
chantent
Jésus la lumière du
monde gloire
au
nouveau-né
Roi
Jésus la lumière du
monde
[Musique]
les Anges
Chantent
Jésus il la lumière sur le
monde
[Musique]
gloire
au nouveau-né
Roi
Jésus il est la lumière il est la lumière  du
monde oh nous allons marcher dans la
lumière dans la lumière une si belle
[Musique]
lumière ne viendras-tu pas où faire où aller de la
miséricorde de Merc
sh
[Musique]
sh la lumière de la
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh mon Dieu de
vivre une si belle
vie [Musique] W tu viens où
[Musique]
la [
Musique]
Jésus
Jésus est une
lumière oh
[Musique]
Jésus il
est il est alha et
Omega le début  et la fin oh
Jésus, il est la
lumière, il est la lumière,
Jésus, il est la lumière, il est la lumière du
monde [Musique] [
Musique]
c'est merveilleux c'est merveilleux c'est
merveilleux bonne chance mon bébé c'est merveilleux
c'est merveilleux c'est merveilleux
Je rêve de toi chips
[  Musique]
chips
[Musique]
merveilleux c'est merveilleux c'est
merveilleux bonne chance mon bébé c'est merveilleux c'est
merveilleux oui merveilleux super quelques chips
chips
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
chips
[Musique]
c'est merveilleux c'est merveilleux c'est
merveilleux bonne chance mon bébé c'est
merveilleux  c'est merveilleux c'est merveilleux
que Dre d'entre vous chips
[Musique]
chips [
Musique]
avant [
Musique] [
Musique]
speee
[Musique] [
Musique]
avant [
[Musique]
pour
étrangère
[Musique]
avant
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sois grande et T et jeune et charmante la
fille
de va à travers et quand elle passe devant
chacun, elle passe
[Musique]
va quand elle marche, elle est comme une
That Swing si cool et se balance si doucement
que quand elle croise chacun d'entre eux, elle passe,
va
oh mais lui les observateurs sont si
tristes,
comment peut-il lui dire qu'il l'aime
oui, il donnerait son cœur
avec plaisir mais chaque jour quand elle marche
vers la mer, elle regarde droit devant lui, pas
lui et mince et  Jeune et charmante, la
fille du soir se promène et quand
elle passe, elle sourit mais elle ne
voit pas, elle ne voit pas, elle ne
voit pas, elle ne voit pas [
Musique]
voir [
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
forto
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
spe
pour me donner
que
[Musique]
avant de donner
Mee
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
avant, donne-
moi, donne-moi
[Musique]
moi [Musique]
donne
oh
[Musique]
c'est
toi ma tête
[Musique] [
Musique]
Shing
[Musique]
oh [
Musique]
vas-y [Musique
]
[Musique] je te vois
Shing  maintenant
[Musique]
oh
[Musique] [Musique
]
oh [
Musique]
merci mesdames et
messieurs pour la jeune génération,
nous aimerions faire notre dernier
enregistrement [Musique] hey Mis hey
Mis j'ai besoin d'une paire  de
chaussures ces grosses ces grosses bottes pour
t'éloigner mon bleu
tu n'arrêtes pas de dire que tu as quelque chose pour
moi quelque chose que tu appelles de l'amour mais
avoue que tu es dans un état de désordre où tu
n'aurais pas dû être un
moi et maintenant quelqu'un d'autre reçoit  tu fais de
ton mieux parce que ces bottes je suis pour
marcher et c'est exactement ce qu'ils font un
de ces jours Ces bottes vont te
marcher dessus tu
n'arrêtes pas de dire que tu n'as jamais été
un
lion tu n'arrêtes pas de dire que tu n'en
auras
jamais jamais  F et tu n'arrêtes pas de dire que tu n'as
jamais été la
vérité, eh bien, ce qui est bien est bien
bébé, tu n'as pas encore eu raison parce que je suis obligé
d'entrer et c'est exactement ce qu'ils font.
Un de ces jours, je dois te marcher
dessus, viens  Continue et marche
Boo, viens et marche
BR, viens et
marche, marche partout
ici, tu n'arrêtes pas de dire que tu n'as jamais été
une
pièce de théâtre, tu n'arrêtes pas de dire que tu n'iras jamais
mieux, je viens de me trouver une toute nouvelle
magie et quoi  il sait que peut-être tu n'as pas le
temps d'
apprendre CU Ces bottes sont faites pour
marcher et c'est exactement ce qu'elles font un
de ces jours c'est boo je dois marcher
partout sur toi viens te promener je dis tu marches
viens te promener je  dis que tu marches viens
marcher bottes marche bottes viens marche
bottes marche bottes
hey marche partout sur lui viens et marche démarre-le bébé
boot-le le
sale
rat donne-lui un coup de pied des bottes donne-
lui un coup de pied je sa je sauve
garde Mo viens et marche oh
marche ouais marche marche
viens marche marche marche par
ici marche marche marche partout ici marche marche
dessus marche marche marche dessus botte-le donne-
lui un coup de pied
Ces bottes sont faites pour
[Musique]
un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore
le
Le dri près de ma
fenêtre l'automne
Le oh rouge et
or je vois ton
[Musique]
face à ce Su
embrasse le soleil bur
h
[Musique]
j'avais l'habitude de
tenir Depuis que tu es
parti les jours GRE
longs et bientôt je
[Musique]
ici
vieille
[Musique]
mais tu me manques
le plus mon
audace [
Musique]
nous
sommes
à
[Musique]
pour ouais